belle tutti ragazzi minuti vi sono video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su gta v
ha fatto un sacco di challenger ove fino
ad oggi di gta punto di gta di mode
incredibili
oggi proviamo bike challenge scusa ma
bike challenge sarebbe sorta di sfida
dove c'è una roba adesso ci giochiamo
sto facendo qualche cagate ragazzi
perché volevo vedere se riuscivo a
recuperare quella macchina li strana che
cappotta tutte le altre ma non sono mai
più riuscito a trovarla non so neanche
come si chiama non ne ho la minima idea
volevo fare esattamente questo però va
dai ragazzi chi se ne frega andiamo
direttamente sul bike challenge che se
non erro dovrebbe essere questo
teoricamente se carica porca vacca ma lo
puoi anche fare con una macchina questo
non sembra per niente un buy back farlo
con una macchina per curiosità solo per
vedere cosa succede a massimo che abbia
comunque ragazzi buy cialis sono
veramente figli a capisco la madonna è
molto più incasinato di quanto pensassi
va bene scherzavo possiamo tornare sopra
la sua per capire se potevo farlo con
una macchina è ingente mente dei ragazzi
proviamoci 321 let's go non ancora
provato a fare niente quindi non è ieri
come sia porca vacca fatica ho rischiato
già subito mi sa che stamo tour è
veramente veloce forse troppo
addirittura 9 rate giusta sono io che
sono storto come la morte aiuto dove
centra cento nel centro c'entrano molto
bene dovrei esserci riuscito
teoricamente spezza ma come faccio andar
giù qualcuno mi spiega come faccio a
prendere quella roba lì da il fratello
dai proci mamma mia quanto devo andare
veloce o storia afferma più piano piano
per favore ok
dolce su cristian a posto ma basta per
favore basta c'è poi c'è poi è stato
difficilissimo fare sta roba
va bene il primo pezzo di un fatto
andiamo avanti
proviamo vedere cosa sai cosa esce fuori
a sta roba io non so non l'ho mai
neanche provato ovviamente come sempre
però sembra veramente sembrava più [ __ ]
finora tra tutte le mappe che ho fatto
sempre di moto sembra più [ __ ]
poi c'è un po di wall ride vorrei
sarebbe quando cavalchi il muro molto
figo proceduto poi vorrei dove è
difficile porca vacca perché fare il
wall ride e è difficilissimo tenere la
moto ragazzi infatti sono caduto porco
demonio ok ok ok qui è difficile tenerlo
poi difficile tenerlo difficile tenerlo
ma ce lo devo fare
puoi fare zio bravo poi mettete poi ti
prego perché vorrei sono i fissi in x
men d'altro e bellissima la vista
insomma che si metta guarda alla vista
hd 0,3 secondi
proviamoci molto bene
non so dove stiamo andando proviamoci lo
stesso anzi mette un'altra visuale tanto
abbiamo altri ci provo oggi gesù ci sono
arrivato come come non ho visto niente
non sono affatto fare tutto sto casino è
veramente fighissimo farlo questa
visuale perché non capisci niente devi
solo fidarti di te stesso allora
aspettato che ci riprova ok no perché
sono scarso ok ok ok ok non solo era la
facciamo così non facciamo con la roba
di prima perché sono un casino
ci provo velocissimo eh vabbè mammamia
tenere la moto è difficilissimo ragazzi
sui salti porca vacca
allora ragazzi è importante arrivare
alla fine con la rampa lì e poi d'acqua
teoricamente dovrei riuscire a rimanere
fermo qui devo centrali già da adesso
cosa che non riesco a fare
concentrato concentra troppo da schifo
per ok aspetta ma anche l'ultimo cia
dovrei aver fatta piano piano piano per
favore della madonna
teoricamente se mi tengo al centro
questa roba qua la posso fare con questa
visuale quale solo cambio la posso fare
con questa visuale qui teoricamente tre
salti dovrei rimanere al centro e basta
sono abbastanza bravo ce la faccio sono
bravissimo ok a barbiano ok una via di
mezzo la voli prima ecologia del social
breve
amen perfetto check points permettete
visto che ci ho messo sei anni a
buongiorno buongiorno gente mi scusi ma
le pare il momento di stare qui ma ma mi
scusi ma
[Musica]
le auguro una buona giornata
a quanto pare ragazzi quando store e
ogni volta sta roba c'è sempre gente
sulle panchine non so come mai non ho
capito sta cosa però ok la presenza o
fatto almeno c'è poi anche domenico più
però unisi perché non mi ricordo
assolutamente solo mezzo inventato io
fino a cadere
ok c'è mi ricordo che ho detto metto c'è
poi in fondo mi dicono solo
effettivamente messo perfetto perfetto
sono stato bravissimo
ok fino qualche piano dio mio ok a
questa era tipo l'altro nella voce fatto
una roba da un autobus
però non c'è il salto stavolta è
collegato mamma mia quanto difficile qua
devo andare veloce verso non cado giù
anno l'avevo visto che c'era una rampa
l'avevo visto come la rampa va bene ok
ok ok ok buono
mamma mia che player non so dove devo
andare vado a caso la vita è veramente
brutta
vai veloce zio veloce veloce prendi il
salto giusto molto bene qua devo andare
non capisco devo dare ve lo show piano
aveva una via di mezzo dai ogni volta
che non ci arrivo salto per arrivarci un
pelo di più e noi non ci arrivò mai
raga è difficilissimo ci credo che culo
molto bene vai vai vai vecchio credi ci
sono fatta
non si sa come ragazzi ce l'ho fatta
bene così l'importante riuscirci poi chi
se ne frega di come l'hai fatto bene io
assisto a scavalcarlo proprio e si
riesce incredibile benvenuto per una
volta e mi viene un'idea e funziona
pazzesco
anche qui brava mamma mia qualche
giocatore è incredibile guarda lo guarda
lo guarda lo mamma che cosa ho fatto
può al quale lo sono meritato c'è poi
aspettati ok quanto manca per la fine di
tutte quella strada lì ma sì che forse
siamo quasi alla fine non lo so quando
alla fine processo potremo così essere
avanti avanti avanti avanti ho detto
avanti molto bene avanti avanti avanti
avanti ok qua è un casino come fai a
fare tutta sta roba senza cadere o gesù
piano piano piano piano bravo ok ce lo
fa come queste storto ma come dovrei
farlo questo storto maraga aiuto queste
storto fermi da fare qui devo andare a
lato mamma mia se no va beh voglio
morire ma non si può fare o forse sì
complotto io cioè statuto un esterno è
un mio dio nola rae possibile è
possibile ci credo ciclo ci credo ciò
che ho fatto sono morte ce lo fanno sto
creando alle scale a posto chi è calmati
calmati calmati sono un casino va bene
va bene
mi ha fatto piano piano piano a posto e
stato un casino ma andiamo verso il
finale che non ho capito dove appunto
dicevo non ho capito bene dove finale
solo che so che da questa parte quindi
baci spedito madonna ci hanno messo
ostacoli ovunque allora siccome c'è un
pezzettino che dovrei fare piano voglio
vedere se scoprendoli velocità risi è
scapolo lo stesso non sono riusciti
piano piano per questo devo fare per
forza così
beh dai onesto onesto piano gesù piano
piano ti ma per favore piano piano piano
piano piatto ok
dove devo andare di qua ma scusami ma di
qua non ci hanno dato anche prima ma no
ma io non ho capito devo andare di qua
scusa ma allora scusatemi ragazzi
semplice quello è il pezzo che ho fatto
prima e un cerchio
una volta arrivato qua dove devo andare
ma scusa non ho capito ma l'ho finito è
praticamente finito c'è quale finale un
finale stranissimo cioè non c'è un
finale per questo il finale questo qua
perché poi non c'è quel ritorno dove la
prima quindi allora che non ci sia
qualcosa sotto
ma impossibile quella in fila porca
vacca bellissimo che cade da 8mila
chilometri e grida una roba tipo o
riparare ragazzi e era il finale quello
strano però perché fatto tutto un casino
e poi finale tutto strano questo era il
bike challenge e mi dispiace solo per il
finale che è bruttino non mi piace un
dove è cresciuto il finale era bello
tutto figo molto più figo degli altri
tipo di che ho fatto tranne il finale
che non era il massimo
va bene ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto è stato di molto difficile
molto più difficile degli altri questo
però anche molto più bello cosa che se
vi piace mi piace anche alcune donne
iniziare se non dovresti chiedere era
come sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo
pic nic
vorrei uno dogs è possibile ma perché
lei 9 lo più che a lui non lei aiuto
non volevo ferirti ahia ahia non volevo
rovinarvi picnic scusate non avevo
capito questa qua e là regalo è una mia
amica allora si allontani sono
allontanati sono pagate addosso
allora è il mio momento di rivincita
amico mio il mio momento di rivincita
ciao pablo mancato adesso
[Musica]